[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum ryan's here with me hi
ryan howdy michael it's good to have you
guys with me um amanda klutz is on the
show if you don't know her very
inspirational she's on the talk she has
a crazy inspiring tragic story to tell
and uh it was really wonderful having
her on the um on the pockets we'll get
to that in just a minute but i
appreciate it if you enjoy the podcast
today and you're here for amanda
i hope maybe you'll subscribe write a
review and and stick around because uh
you know i think you'll like the show uh
tell them about the handles they could
follow us on the uh twitter and
instagram and facebook at insideviewpod
on twitter at insiderviewpodcast on
instagram and facebook that's correct
and uh if you want to you can watch on
youtube you could listen to the podcast
pretty much everywhere and write a
review tell us what you think also um i
got merch on the inside of you online
store lex luthor stuff smallville stuff
inside of you stuff
also the bandsunspin.com you could book
zooms with me and rob from the band and
you can book the band and you can get a
bunch of cool merch there sunspin.com
and lastly patreon.com if you want to
join the wonderful family that
subscribes uh and gives a little more to
the podcast if you're enjoying the
podcast you want to help the podcast a
little more join patreon just go to
patreon p-a-t-r-e-o-n dot com slash
inside of you and i'll send you a
message
thanking you and you can join the family
and there's a lot of goodies there yeah
thank you for watching the stage at show
last week we had a great time and um it
was nice seeing everybody out there and
listening us play music ryan good week
yeah okay week yeah not two shabs not
two shabs did you leave that stuff we
talked about um
in the podcast about covid yeah i left
the whole thing oh good yeah good it was
a good it was a good conversation
i think it was helpful i think it's
helpful yeah yeah so i think if he's
also talking about like you know
confronting you know things that might
bother you and you know we talked
something through we did a little more
so we understood each other we did and i
also thought it was helpful
if anyone thinks they may or may not
have the disease and you know what to
sort of do about it and this was sort of
a situation and i think it might help
anyone out there who
um doesn't exactly know what to do
doesn't know what to do yeah yeah they
might be confronted with that situation
and how to handle it yeah exactly if
you're feeling sick or a little down
you're like ah it's probably nothing go
get tested
you'll get tested i mean
you just be careful uh let's just go
right into this and stick around uh
we'll talk goodies i read patreon names
uh top tier patrons and a bunch of other
stuff but right now let's just get
inside of the wonderful beautiful amanda
clutes it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience you're an inspiration i i read
all your posts which either make me cry
or make me smile the little boy elvis is
just to die for he's the sweetest little
thing i've ever seen in my life and
um and you've got this book out live
your life and obviously
i haven't read it yet i'm a slow reader
but
i i assume it's
about i mean do you lay everything pen
to paper do you put everything
out there like everything you could
think of as dark
as you your mind gets do you write it
down or there's some things that you go
you know what this is too much no i
really did b wrote the honest story of
exactly what happened and i'm very
honest about everything about nick and
i's relationship the highs and the lows
the everything that we i went through at
the hospital
the battles that we fought on a daily
basis with the hospital um all the
things it's all in there and i think
that's what's special about this book if
for anyone that followed the story
you think you know the story because you
were with me every day following it but
what you don't know is that you know
oftentimes on social media we we share
we share the tip of the iceberg
and you're not seeing what is underneath
the water
right i mean it's a lot and we'll get
there i want to get there but i do want
to i want to talk about like the amanda
before all this happened before you got
into the acting and one of the hosts of
the talk and wrote a book and went
through all this you know drama for lack
of a better word again but i mean what
was life like back i mean you this
sounds like a stephen king title plane
township stark county ohio
i know is that where you're from
yeah
what did you do in plain town i don't
even know what that means plain township
it's a township that's plain in stark
county ohio
um yeah i mean it's a lot of
you know farms and um i mean honestly
though i would my neighborhood it looks
like a norman rockwell painting it was
beautiful
covered tree-lined covered streets uh
dairy queen at the corner my elementary
school at the corner you've walked
school
white wicked fences green grass um you
know we would be playing down the street
and my dad would just do a huge whistle
and it was like oh time to go home
dinner's ready gotta go leave it to
beaver it was leave it to beaver in a
lot of ways it would leave it to beaver
yes it was oh my gosh often times my mom
and dad didn't even know where we were i
mean we just had to hear the whistle and
we knew it was time to come home for
dinner so i mean growing up was it was
did you have a pretty fun life i mean
were your parents cool did you have good
relationships with them
growing up was great i have one brother
four sisters
um
anna my little sister who wrote the book
with me is seven years younger so when
anna was born she was like our real life
barbie doll our baby doll not barbie
doll baby doll
um and we
you know we were a big old happy family
family vacations
um every summer to hilton head island
we'd all pile in the van you know friday
nights you're watching
you know a movie that we all rented from
video time you know
ice cream parties family dinner every
night at 6 p.m church every sunday i
mean it was what
yeah so
most people either avoid that if they
had such a great childhood they don't
like to share it but you know the
juxtaposition of like what you've gone
through it's really nice to know that
you had this
i mean that's a nice through line i mean
you're backwards but oh my god no it's
because of that that i am the person i
am today that my family you know that my
sister and brother came to rescue me at
the time that they did that
you know
we're each other's best friends uh we
really are my my mom and dad
taught us to always put family first
and uh and we really we really do we
love each other so much if we could all
live in the same block we would i
honestly i'm sorry to say this but i
can't say the same for my family yeah i
don't you know ryan my engineer here my
buddy
he just saw his uh his girlfriends he
went to see their family for like nine
days and i got an anxiety i got an
anxiety attack from that do you
understand i couldn't be with look i
love my family but i could i can't last
more than two days with them it's just
there's a but there's a difference with
us there's it's just it's it was highly
dysfunctional growing up it was
sort of a mess so i could understand why
you could gravitate towards that it's
some normalcy
real love they they listen to you when
you when you told them you wanted i mean
what age did you want to go into
entertainment and how did they respond i
wrote an essay in sixth grade about
wanting to be a radio city rocket and on
broadway
and then when i was in high school and i
started doing the musicals in high
school that's when i was like i think
this is what i want to do
i took some good convincing though my
dad especially was like
you know you should go to a four-year
college and then if you really still
believe that you want to do this go to
new york then and i was like you know no
dad i have to go to new york now
and um luckily got into amndo which is a
two-year musical theater conservatory
and he finally my mom and my dad finally
said okay
you can do this but just know that if it
doesn't work out the money for the two
years that you're going to be spending
in new york is this equivalent to the
four years we spent on your brother and
sisters
so after these two years if if nothing
happens you're on your own and you're 20
years old without a college degree
and i said i don't care i want to do
this
and so they they let me because deep
down you knew they'd still help you
i think yes of course but i also deep
down knew that i was going to do it
right so i have an exhibition like that
so how long from this time you started
this thing this two-year program
until you started to see some success
and things started turning around a
little bit i mean it happened pretty
fast two days before i graduated i
booked my first national tour of a
broadway show and what was that 42nd
street two days before it ended you
called your parents and they're like up
two days left she's got [ __ ] going on
there's nothing going on and you got
this and they were were they screaming
on the phone oh my gosh of course i saw
a 42nd street 10 times in the front row
student tickets
um i worked my butt off i went to that
audition twice before it got cut right
away it was the third time i auditioned
for the show
i had worked really hard on my singing
and my tap dancing especially because
that show was all tap
and so when i got that job it was it was
a i mean it was huge it was huge what's
your thing what would you rather do sing
or dance are you equally good at both of
those no i'm much more i i was trained
as a dancer and then i learned how to
sing in college or
at the conservatory but i didn't
actually really learn how to sing and
use my voice until i was doing broadway
shows and when did the broadway started
to happen when did that happen well 42nd
street was the broadway national tour of
the revival that was on broadway at the
time right and do those pay well by the
way are those like something that you
they make what is how does that work
well it just depends
back in the day you would die to get a
broadway show national tour because
you would make broadway salary but then
you would also make per diem on top of
that
and if you were smart with your per diem
you could basically bank your salary and
live off of like half of your per diem
so a lot of actors would
prefer to be on a national tour because
of those contracts you could you could
come home from a national tour and buy a
home you know or buy an apartment
um and then you know as the world
changes those contracts started getting
kind of um
torn apart and so the 42nd street
national tour job that i got was the
first of the they called them the ceta
contracts and my salary was about an
eighth of what an an actual broadway
salary should have been and our premium
was again about like a fourth of what it
should have been
but i was 20 i didn't care i was like i
would have done the job for free i
remember the first day that they said
paychecks are here come get your
paycheck i looked at my girlfriend i was
like
oh my gosh that's right we get paid like
i i completely forgot i just was so
happy to be there dancing isn't it funny
how he gets so jaded first thing we're
saying i was like well how much do i get
for that now we're not like i'll do it
i'll just do it i just want to ask i
want to dance right what happened now
it's like i mean look if the right job
comes along
and a house and a mortgage payment and
car payments and at 20 or you know
you're living in a college dorm or
you're sharing an apartment with 10
people so you don't have to worry about
that by the way i think i would be more
out i mean look if spielberg ever called
or any of these big directors and said
we want you to do this part i wouldn't
care about money at all i'm like i'm in
i don't care there's certain jobs you
don't care about but when you take most
jobs it's like all right i gotta
i gotta pay for my mortgage here i gotta
do this i gotta pay for my mom's
mortgage i to help my sister out these
are things that i have to do uh by the
way
when did your parents finally first see
that show how soon after you went on
tour um they came to quickly after we
opened we opened at kansas city
starlight theater which is an outdoor
amphitheater very much similar to the
hollywood bowl
and it was magical but then like two
cities later we were in
columbus or no cincinnati ohio and
because i'm from ohio that's where they
first saw the show drove down to
cincinnati and saw it there did you get
nervous to get more nervous when people
are there no not my family um
no you know if i am nervous i'll get
nervous a little bit before but then
once i'm on stage
i go it goes away immediately
even no matter what i do um performing
wise it's always if there's nerves it's
just right there
you know but that fuels my fire i
actually use it to help my adrenaline i
bet your dad cried i'm gonna i'd put all
my money on it oh they all did they all
did they were all crying afterwards they
came up to you may i do we just knew it
even though it was two days before you
graduated we knew it was gonna happen
and we were gonna help you if you didn't
make it you know that right
it was that way yes that was a big day i
would say my dad and and my mom probably
teared up more so when i did the radio
city rockets though and they were at
that opening night that opening night
for them was you know my dad's still no
matter where we are no matter what i do
in my life if we're sitting at a
restaurant he'll be like to the waitress
my daughter was a radio city rocket you
know
i want to hear
see that's pretty sweet you know i
remember doing theater in college and
then after
after college was over in new york like
off-broadway but i'm talking off off
like new jersey broadway
it wasn't really broadway but you know
that little click that they have the
green room click the uh all those actors
backstage it's more drama than you can
imagine i'm sure you know that more than
anyone doesn't everybody just sleep with
everybody on these tours did you
experience that on these tours were
people just banging everybody oh my god
um
what happens on tour stays on tour it is
a crazy life and you are not too far
from the truth my friend yeah i assume
did you were there any loves though that
you kind of fell in love with like um
early on
uh on the broadway circuit well i met
both of my husbands in shows but on
broadway shows on tour
um i never fell in love with anybody but
i saw a lot of relationships and a lot
of people
doing things they shouldn't be doing
late at night you know tour is such an
alternate lifestyle you have no
responsibilities you are in these weird
cities in hotel rooms and
you have you can sleep all day the only
thing you have to do is go to your show
at night and then the show ends and you
have nothing to do but go to the bar
next door and stay there way too long
and then past 2 a.m things start
happening that this shouldn't happen so
yeah this is exactly why you guys out
there listening you always hear about
these hollywood you read the tabloids
it's so much fun because everybody's
cheating and all these big movie stars
it starts out at an early age it starts
out on tour it starts out in the green
room in college you get a lot of alone
time a lot of
you i'm lonely i i and you want to have
fun and your talent is sexy talent is
sexy when you see somebody all of a
sudden that you don't think is cute get
up there and like belt out a song and
then go into a dance and then the
audience applaud you're like
wow you know she's cute why am i all of
a sudden liking you know matt
isn't that funny how people like women
tell me if i'm wrong i mean you like
funny guys you like or talented guys so
you see town even if you might not look
at them on the street if you didn't know
them and you walked by and you'd be like
you i wouldn't look twice at this guy he
gets up there and belt something out
maria i just met a girl right and you
just like holy [ __ ] you know why it
shows vulnerability it's like you're
you're
you know showing your soul especially
with i think anything live
live music live theater
you know you're like you're being real
and raw you there's like an honesty that
you have to like get to and and showcase
you know you're crying in front of
people you're
you're being brave in front of people
you're you know
it's you're showing your different
colors it's i think and it's i think
that's what makes it attractive so when
you were talking about a while ago you
said like in sixth grade or seventh
grade that you wanted to be a rock set
was that right
you wrote this thing out saying i want
to be a rock set at
whatever years old and now how old
before you get your audition for the
rock sets rock sets rock set broadcast
did i say do you know why because you
know why because roxat is one of my
favorite 80s bands and i keep saying it
remember that song she's got the look
what in the world can make a brighter
bar turn blue oh yeah good song you say
sorry so not rock set the rock cats no
it's okay
um yes it's the rockettes yes so
um
the rockettes i have first auditioned
for the rockets when i was going to
school
in new york
i auditioned for the national tour of
the rockettes because at the time
there was the radio city
crew and then there were rockets in all
these other cities doing the christmas
show in st louis or in columbus or
chicago
so i thought i would go to those
auditions and maybe have a better chance
at getting that job first
and i got cut and then i went back again
to another audition got cut and so my
third audition again was for the actual
radio city rockets
and that was while i was on tour with
42nd street
and um i flew from la to new york to
that audition spent two days it was like
a thousand girls there they needed 12
and after two days i ended up getting
dumped those high kicks i mean how hard
is that to get those kicks right and
what was it in the first two auditions
that you think
that they give you notes like well you
know your heels to the right uh too much
i don't know what you do you're doing
something wrong they tell you what
you're doing wrong so you can come back
and correct it oh yeah your head was um
it's it's uh you know they'll say like
looking to the sun so like your chin is
like you're looking to the sun
but if it's this way you're like you
know your chin was an inch low so you
got to lift it up or you know your pinky
was out so you put it in i mean it is so
detailed
i mean it's all about you know being
uniform so you have to be like it's
precision precision dance at its best
you're like a marine you're like the
marines it's like everything has to be
precise yeah the goal the goal of the
rockets is to not stick out right you
don't want to be an individual you want
to be one of 36.
so the heart honestly the hardest thing
about the kicks is that you have to kick
its eye high so your toe to your eye so
it can't be higher it can't be lower
that is so it's not necessarily it's not
like oh my gosh is that so hard to kick
your your do the high high do the high
kicks it's it's more so you have to hit
a target
that is like right in front of you that
is like a laser beam that no one else
can see except you know your imagination
and
that's i think that's the hardest part
about the kicks was that though
go ahead
oh that and like when i was a rocket i
did five shows in one day so it was you
know you're doing you know a ridiculous
amount of of uh activity
i mean i i guess the first time you
auditioned you just it was like you were
[ __ ] kicking you were just trying to
in a way you're probably trying to stand
out when you weren't supposed to stand
out no i knew not to stand out um my
first two auditions i just i i you have
to learn it's a process
you just you know and it's intimidating
you're auditioning at the grand hall at
radio city musical there's a lot of
girls everybody looks the same because
it's again about having a certain look
and height
um
so i think it was just about like
learning and being confident and and
getting super sharp in your dancing and
and you know you have to be good and i
just i wasn't good enough the first two
times then i got good
inside of you is brought to you by
geico
geico how have you not ever heard the
word geico ryan seriously i've heard of
it yeah of course and everyone out there
hasn't heard of it everyone's heard of
geico and you should really hear about
them now because they have these
bundling policies and i don't know about
you but it is a pain in the butt to pay
your homeowners or renters insurance or
your auto insurance so if you could just
do all in one
why wouldn't you and that's geico's
bundling policy it's pretty easy i mean
it's simple it's geico easy a and bomb
that i can do this
it's uh
they make things convenient for you you
know like i don't like to go to the
grocery store i've talked about that so
you don't need to there's services
so why not have a bundling policy with
geico you just do this you go to
geico.com
and you get a quote and you see how much
you could save it's geico easy all you
do is visit
geico.com today
that's
geico.com
get your bundling policies now at geico
inside of you is brought to you by un
tucket two tears in a bucket untuck it
guys
i don't know about you but i'm the guy
that used to wear like these nice you
know button-down shirt it would hang
down to my knees because they weren't
designed to be just worn outside of your
uh you know your your what do you call
it pants your pants you know like over
your pants and uh untuck it
makes shirts
fitted for you that can be worn untucked
hence
untucked
and summer's here and there's never been
a better time to try a shirt from untuck
it they have performance shirts that
wick sweat
also short sleeve button downs and polos
are made to beat the heat untucked
shirts are perfect as we transition back
to the things we've been missing like
dinners with friends reuniting with
family and vacations too untuck it makes
shirts designed to be worn
untucked you've got to try these check
me out pretty sweet huh it's a damn good
shirt right there they have fits for all
shapes and sizes untuck it offers up to
triple xl plus they have slim relaxed
and tall fits untuck it has 85 stores
nationwide free returns and exchanges
and all you have to do is try it try
them at untuck it use the code inside
for 20 off your first purchase at
untuckit.com code inside for 20 off your
first purchase at untuckit.com
give my friends in untucky to visit
inside of you is brought to you by
charlie bear of got pet products the
family behind charlie bear is also
behind a human ingredient company that
has been bringing expertise creative
imagination and a passion for food to
people for more than a century these
charlie bear treats my dogs crazy about
it's simply amazing and they're hound
and gatosk food blanche cannot have
enough of it look at her eating it every
day the charlie bear treats are natural
dog treats from our family to your best
friend they're made in the us of a
simple natural ingredients low calories
blanche i'd like to lose a few pounds
you know what i mean they have only
three calories each pocket friendly will
not crumble and make a mess in your
pocket wallet-friendly high-value
rewards and most importantly your dog
will love them look for charlie bear
products at your favorite neighborhood
pet stores and online or visit our
website at
www.charliebear that's
c-h-a-r-l-e-e-b-e-a-r
www.charliebear.com for more information
also you can go to www.houndgatos
h-o-u-n-d-g-a-t-o-s and get some of this
delicious food that you saw blanche
eating minutes ago i want to give a
shout out to my brother who works for
got and uh thanks for being a sponsor
they're fantastic once again just go to
www.charliebear.com for more information
on this great product or
houndgatos.com
do you remember the conversation when
you when you called your dad and said
i'm a rock son ruckette
i'm i'm in the band rock set yeah i do i
um well ironically my parents had flown
into new york for the two days that i
had the audition and you know the first
day you go through many cuts the second
day they give you a call back so you
come back they go through a lot of cuts
my dad picked me up at the stage store
at radio city and um
after the second day we all went to a
big family dinner he said how'd it go
and i was like i think i did good dad
you know i don't know
and i had to fly back the next day to la
to go back on tour with 42nd street so i
landed at lax and i was walking off the
plane i saw that i had an email saying
please call us and i'm walking through
lax i'm still to this day when i pass
this spot at lax airport i'm like that's
where i found out that i got to be a
radio city rocket and i i called them
immediately afterwards and they were
floored they were so excited i mean was
it the biggest achievement i mean i
guess at that time of your life was it
better than getting 42nd street was it
better than anything you had done like
i'm a rocket yeah you know that i think
that was a that was a huge achievement
because 42nd street was still a national
tour it wasn't like my broadway debut
um which broadway debut came after
rockettes but yeah the broadcast was a
huge
that was a lifelong dream of mine and
that and like i said it was a thousand
girls they needed 12. so that was it was
a huge accomplishment now i'm not
comparing laker girls to rockettes the
rockettes i'm not going to do that i'm
not saying that but i know for a fact
that laker girls laker girls do you know
every time they go to dance the guy i
think he just gets paid to say
liquor girls oh that's what he does i'm
like that's the only thing that guy says
but they don't get paid very much like
they i hear they get paid a hundred
dollars a night
now rockettes they got to get paid
pretty well right no we are treated so
well you get paid very well you get um
you know you have beautiful dressing
rooms they have a full like floor of pt
for you um that you know you can go to
at any time ice baths that we all go
into right after the show
they give you scholarship money so that
on the off season you can go to school
and further your education they give you
money to um you know uh do dance classes
so that you can you know keep your you
know your ability up it is a it is a
very very good job 401k
you know it's wonderful they treat you
very well this is remarkable i don't
think anybody knows any of this they
assume it's probably a low-paying job
that's just like they make a lot of
money but the girls don't make a lot of
money but they you're saying they treat
you right and you did you know what you
were getting into in terms of uh the pt
room and all these scholarships and all
these things you had no idea until you
were a rockette yeah no i mean you know
again i was i was making pennies on the
42nd street tour but happy as a clam
and when i got that job i was like i
make this wow
and i get all i get this too and i can
like go to school to get my you know
yoga certification and teach yoga like
oh cool and
you know i mean no i was i was 22 years
old i i was like i was green as all get
out how many guys were coming on to you
i mean a rock cat has to be the coolest
thing to say i'm going out with a raw
cat
i mean you have to be hit on i mean
obviously a very pretty girl anyway very
talented all these things but to be a
rockette is like that's that's like a
dallas
dallas cowboy cheerleader back in the
day
right i michael i really you know
i i never really had a lot of boyfriends
i honestly and or dated a lot i so
honestly that really did not happen to
me too much you fall fast is what you're
saying you fall for someone quickly and
then that's it you're a monogamous one
guy only girl
no you know i don't think i fall for
somebody fast actually um i just you
know i met my first husband in a show
and again like
i think just like the repetitive um
seeing somebody every day and then
seeing their talent every day and it
just became attractive and then
i'm a person that uh
is friendly first and then through
friendship i start to like you
huh
i think well that's interesting that's
that's probably the smart thing to do
you get to know someone i like this
person i like how they make me feel they
make me laugh they're fun to be around
and then things start to happen yeah
natural organic i guess yeah i don't
know i mean
and then that's how i met nick too so
yeah i don't know now i'm now i'm
screwed because i'm on a talk show with
all women so
the time o'connell just joined our show
so he did because they said that it was
the deal was breaking soon so it broke
yes yeah it broke today yes so now you
got a dude on the show which is probably
fun for you because it's like talking to
girls the whole time probably got boring
for you you do that it's wonderful no
jerry brings so much energy and um i
love having you know the male energy
there and it's it's great no jerry's the
best he actually
i did the hollywood bowl with his wife
rebecca we did the producers at the
hollywood bowl together and then jerry
and i did crazy for you at lincoln
center together in new york so i've
known jerry for a while so it's
wonderful to now be working with him on
the top how old were you when you got
bullets over broadway a musical i was 30
to 31 31 so last month
you just got it um bullets over broadway
and that was a big thing for you right
yeah it was a big deal because it was
woody allen directing with susan
strowman and um
slated to be you know the next big big
show on broadway i got that job thinking
i would be on broadway for three years
i'd be able to have three kids and you
know have you know be able to buy a
house were you already divorced when you
were doing bullets no i was still with
my first husband and um he was doing the
national tour of book of mormon
so he was on he was leaving for tour as
i was starting bullets over broadway so
it was hard because when you're starting
a broadway show you have no life and you
can go nowhere traveling is not an
option and then he's on the road on the
west coast
leading the book of mormon to her you
know doing a crazy tour schedule he
can't leave either so we left each other
knowing that we wouldn't see each other
often and that we were going to be on
different sides of the country
and i knew from being on three national
tours like we talked about just a second
ago what tour life is like
are you insinuating something happened
while he was on tour i'm insinuating
that tour life is crazy and um
my husband was always the life of the
party
and he's a good guy but yeah to her life
is is crazy so that kind of
sizzled out after a while how long did
that take before it kind of just you
started hearing things or he was honest
with you how does that work there were
things in our marriage that had happened
uh throughout our six years of being
married married together um and you know
you work through them i know i never got
married to get divorced so it was always
something that like you know we just
worked through
and um and then you know two were just
accentuated those problems and made
everything that we always kind of fought
and dealt with even worse and um
and it's okay now you know you you look
at things retrospectively and it was
honestly the best thing that ever
happened to me getting a divorce and
going our separate ways we got married
very young and i think that
you know we found out that we actually
weren't the perfect person for each
other and that's okay you know it was a
very very hard awful thing to go through
i'm not trying to put it lightly because
it wasn't at all
but now retrospectively i can look back
and be like you know what
it's all good how do you put things
aside though while you're sitting there
doing a broadway show with woody allen
directing all these big names and you're
it's broadway and all these things are
happening materialize materializing in
front of you how do you
how do you just separate them how do you
go to work and just separate it how do
you do that that's got to be a a mind
[ __ ] sorry for my language first f-bomb
of the day it totally is all day and
then you walk into a theater and you put
makeup on that makes you look like an
accentuated version of yourself and you
put a wig on it makes you feel like
you're not yourself and then you put on
a really cool costume and then you
really don't feel like yourself and then
you're with this whole family that
um you have a extremely close and
different and new relationship with and
then after the show ends you go to the
bar next door and drown your sours
because you don't want to go home and
sit at your house by yourself and so
then you get drunk and then you repeat
the next day and that was my life that
that was how i coped with it and what
was it like working with woody allen was
he just kind of quiet and distant and
just did his job and then what left and
you didn't really get to talk to him i
guess that's how it feels it probably
would be like yeah yes yes most of the
time and then you had like the the rare
occasions where he would come over and
do cast notes and um
and you know you kind of had to like
pinch yourself that like woody allen's
giving cast notes but he was very quiet
he was he watched
everything all the previews and always
had opinions and things but um yeah he
was he was very quiet he did his own
thing
he was always you know his wife was
there and his daughter was there a lot
and um and they were always always very
kind and and but quiet for sure so nick
cordero
yeah
when you first met him on bullets over
broadway obviously you're married you're
going through all these things
you probably didn't think not anything
of it at first right yeah you're just
working together there's how many people
in this uh the show oh gosh the cast was
probably i don't know like 25 people
right so when was the first time that
you you said huh
um
we
um you know i had known nick because we
did the reading of this show so when a
broadway show
conceptualizes they usually do like a
reading
like a year before or sometimes even
years before so i met nick before so
when we started rehearsals
yeah it was nothing i was i was happily
married um you know or i thought so or
trying to be so um so i just saw nick as
like you know a cool guy in the cast
um but also like you know nick was going
through his own
change he was a starving actor living in
williamsburg and a friend's you know
with like three other roommates i mean
to me he kind of looked like a big like
a mess a little bit like a hot mess of
it um but charming and talented and
funny and extremely tall and you can't
not look at it when he walks in the room
because he's six five dark hair and like
you know
playing the leading man next to zach
braff and so you're like
you know okay this guy's interesting
um and it was one night we were
finishing a preview for no we had opened
the show so you do previews of a
broadway show then you have your big
opening night then the show's open so we
had opened the show
and we were at the bar next door having
you know you know drinks celebrating and
nick and i sat down at the bar and we
just talked the whole night and it was
just one of those
it's in the book but it's one of those
like movie sequences where like
you see the couple talking at the bar
and they're in like real time but
everything around them is happening
in like four times the speed
and you know it came to be like three
o'clock in the morning and you know the
bar is almost empty and we're still
chatting
and i was like obviously i had to go i
was teaching fitness in the morning
and i remember walking to the subway
being like oh no do i like this guy
but exactly what i said like that's what
happens to me like i'm just friends with
friends friends and then all of a sudden
i like you
so
yeah you see all everything about the
person you're like oh you probably see
all the good the bad and then
huh that's interesting so when when how
long did it take before you know did he
make the first move did he kind of say
hey no he wanted nothing to do with me
because i was i was married you know
um and to everyone in the broadway world
which is a very small world i was
married i was not letting anyone know
that my marriage was falling apart that
things were happening certain people in
the cast knew my girlfriends in the cast
knew
and that night i confided a lot to nick
about things that were going on and he
was confiding into me about um his past
relationships and so we had this like
big like kind of heart to heart but yeah
nobody knew and so the last thing nick
wanted to do
and this you know bullets over broadway
was a huge um life changer for him he
got nominated for tony he was you know
he was the star of the show essentially
so he didn't want to get into any
scandal you know so he was like
he was kind of like amanda you know i
like i think you're cool but like also
you're married and i can't be seen with
a married woman so
even as we slowly started to like hang
out he would always be like you know
meet me i'm on the corner or something
like that it was all secretive yeah
because he was so scared to like
ruin his reputation at a time where he
was finally being recognized in the
broadway community for his his artistry
so he's being respectful is what he was
doing yeah
yeah which made me just want to be like
you know
no you know meet me here and then it
doesn't matter you know
so when was it when was that moment do
you remember the moment you're like okay
this is
i think this is going somewhere we're
hanging out a lot we're talking
now maybe we can take this moment and
it's in the book it's in the book live
your life which you guys must read i
mean she she really divulges everything
here and and
you're that kind of person and so look
it's a new york times bestseller for
christ's sakes read read the thing but
go ahead no it was um it was july we
were um we were still doing the show
my marriage was was really
over uh you know i we had talked about
you know officially kind of separating
taking that break and um
and nick took me on a date like an
official like okay this is an official
like first date
and um
because again you know when you're doing
a show together you're hanging out a lot
you're going to the bar after the show a
lot
but none of that's not not like a date
you know what i mean it's it's not a
date at all but you're hanging out all
the time
so he asked me out like on a date date
and we took me out to dinner at this
beautiful restaurant in washington
heights and that was
that was july 6th
so we always celebrated that day as like
our our first date
and then ironically you know he passed
away on july 5th
um so it's crazy you know timing wise
but so after that you kind of knew you
had spent enough time with him you were
friends you were working together and
after that first date on july 6th
you felt like hey
this is it and how fast was it after
that that you guys were together pretty
fast i mean pretty fast yeah pretty fast
but we
we
we had lots of issues we had lots of
fights and broke up like
uh i mean definitely broke up three
times the last time that we broke up i
we we both thought it was over so we we
thought we could fight really well
together what was it were you both just
kind of the same
a personalities in a lot of ways no that
was we were exact opposite nick
um you know next like a dreamer
like you know i mean so am i but in a
different
way
um you know he
you know he's just
you know
smoke weed and just kind of like listen
to music lay on the bed look at the
ceiling kind of you know think about
things and
you know well he's done that for three
hours i've taught ten fitness classes
answered all my emails and i'm about to
create another company so you would get
upset you're like would you get up and
go do something for christ's sakes
you're just sitting here smokey's like
hey i was nominated for a tony so i'm
gonna sit here for a while and smoke
some jewelry yeah and you know we
thought about um you know i was in a
different place in my life i was going
through a divorce
so i had already had seven years of
marriage and i was looking at my life as
like
where what am i doing now i want you
know i'm on my own now
um i've lost that security
i have to create things for myself i
have to
figure out how to make money for myself
i want a home one day i want a family
one day how am i gonna make that happen
and yeah and nick's career was just
starting so he was kind of just being
like
you know in that in that mindset so and
and we thought about religion he was not
religious i was and so
we had a lot of we have a lot of this
sounds amazing how really the love of
your life like how it was meant to be
to get together but like you did fight
it wasn't perfect it was your opposite
people you were doing two different
things you were getting out of this
america i mean it's pretty incredible
how you came together what made that
happen was it just like
regardless of the fights regardless of
whatever there's this underlying
love this
sort of i want to be with you i want to
take care of you
each other yeah i know you know it's
funny i i don't know you know nick when
we were dating he would always say like
we're so different we should not be
together and and i would be like what do
you mean
um
because we were we were it was so
different and um
i think yeah i think there was
underlying love i think you know nick
in the end uh our last breakup his
father passed away or got cancer and
then ended up passing away and in his
father getting cancer at a young age and
passing away i think he it made him
really um just kind of realize like
you know
like all of our differences and like the
things that we fight about
they can all be like we can talk through
these things like the most important
thing is like i don't want to lose you
and and so he came you know he came back
and yeah kind of was like
you know
there was conviction in that there was
there's something different in him you
think that changed when he said those
things yeah a lot of people will say
that when you lose a parent it changes
you especially if it's at a younger age
and you know nick was
39 or 38 when his dad passed and um
and you know and his dad was young and
um
and he's the oldest of his siblings and
and they're very close they have a
beautiful family
and yeah gene i think it just i think it
just helped him to to um grow up a
little bit and and see like what he
wanted in life you know
inside of you is brought to you by
better help better help online therapy
these guys are winners they've been with
me for a while there's a reason it's
because it works
the stigma from mental health is
vanishing it's going away because people
realize when they discuss problems that
they're having or issues or depression
or anxiety if they talk about it with a
licensed therapist it helps one of those
people is me one of those other people
right is across from me and that's ryan
tayez ryan you go to betterhelp we've
talked about this it helps you what is
what do you mostly know
what have you noticed about better help
that's just made a difference in your
life um they provide a very uh warm and
welcoming place to sort of talk through
your stuff right and uh
so far so good yeah i noticed a
difference i noticed when you were
really tense episodes back and you're
just like
i just got a lot of my plate and i'll
play i'm like ryan needs to talk to
someone and you did
you talk to someone and it makes it you
just see your whole disposition it just
changes look guys if you're feeling
depressed or struggling with uncertainty
or having difficulty sleeping better
help offers experienced therapists who
can listen better help will assess your
needs and match you with your own
licensed professional you can start
communicating in under
48 hours the service is available for
clients worldwide you can log into your
account anytime and send a message to
your counselor do you facetime your
counselor ryan or do you text them or no
i get to facetime so you face time with
them so you like to see the person yeah
i think that's important i like to see
the person i'm talking to that's me too
but you don't have to do that you could
uh send a message to your counselor you
could talk to him you can do whatever
you want you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
you'll never have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room as with
traditional therapy betterhelp is
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change counselors if you
need that's a big thing if you don't
like your counselor it's okay i've
switched many counselors but once you
got the guy or the gal or whoever you
need that's right for you life does
change better help is more affordable
than traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is available i could tell
you that it's a lot cheaper so many
people have been using betterhelp that
they are recruiting additional
counselors in all 50 states and inside
of you is sponsored by better help
online therapy now our listeners get 10
off their first month of online therapy
at
betterhelp.com
slash
inside that's better h-e-l-p dot com
inside
get matched with a better health
therapist
and get started
inside of you is brought to you by
public wreck ryan i love wearing
sweatpants you do love wearing
sweatpants i do and i just love comfort
and you know but my friends will make
fun of me they say hey you know you're
wearing come on you wearing sweatpants
put on a nice pair of pants but what if
i told you there's a company public
wreck that has pants
that are as comfortable
as sweatpants that would be interesting
that would be certainly interesting and
it is interesting because they are
amazing you know the thing with regular
sweatpants is the length is never quite
right waist feels too small or too big
no zipper pockets so things fall out or
you put things in your pockets and your
pants sag
it's all the same stuff with you know
the regular sweatpants in public wreck
you don't have to deal with that at all
that's why you've got to check out guys
you got to check out public wreck they
make leisure wear and waist and inseam
sizes because comforts start with a
better fit their best-selling all-day
everyday pants are a more stylish
alternative to sweatpants and a more
comfortable alternative to jeans the
clothing is great for lounging at home
looking sharp for work heading to the
bar and anywhere pants should be worn
the all-day everyday pant comes in waist
and inseam sizing so they fit short guys
tall guys and everybody in between made
from a breathable stretchy moisture
wicking fabric you could wear them 24 7
and they'll look brand new they also
have zipper pockets so no more having
your phone or wallet fall out when you
sit down they come in nine different
colors one for each day of the week and
then some plus they've got incredibly
comfortable shorts t-shirts henleys
polos hoodies jackets even golf wear
and they just launched their women's
line so now anyone listening to this can
enjoy public rec's game-changing fabric
in their wardrobe i've truly never had
pants that fit this well they're the
most comfortable things i've ever worn i
could wear them all the time i do and no
one makes fun of me in fact they look at
me and say
damn those look sharp rosenbaum yeah who
knew you could look so sharp in sweats
that's what i'm saying right as the
world's opening back up make sure you've
got clothes that are as flexible as your
life is public rec
rarely discounts but right now they have
an exclusive offer just for inside of
you listeners folks listen up go to
public rec that's public rec
public rec dot com slash iou to receive
off
that's public rec rec
dot com slash iou
for 10 off public rec.com
10 off
so tell me if i'm wrong but you you go
out to la we fast forward things you
know his his father passes away he has
this
this thought of
you're the one this is it we've got to
do this you guys are together you move
out to l.a am i right about this you
stayed at zac braff's guest house while
you were shopping for a house yeah well
we stayed at zac brabs guest house
because we were still paying rent in our
new york city apartment
um we were subletting it but not for the
whole amount
and um and zach is so generous and he
loves us so much that he was like
stay at my house for free and just kind
of like get your feet wet we had no we
had a goal of buying a home one day but
it definitely wasn't like
we have everything set in place to buy a
home we were just more so it was just
like
we're gonna stay at zax we can live
there for free we can save our money and
see if we like living in l.a and then we
happened to
find a home that we could barely afford
and we bought it and how soon after was
was little elvis conceived well elvis
was conceived
right before we moved to l.a he was
conceived he was well he was born in
june we moved to l.a in september right
so now you got this little munchkin
around you're trying to find a place you
finally got a place
and then things are things seems
things seem pretty damn good at this
point yeah well even well to to
to just give a funny antidote when we
first moved into zack's guest house this
two-bedroom two-bath cottage that he
owns
he was living there because his main
house was being completely renovated you
know i live like right around the corner
yeah anyway but go ahead go ahead yeah
so um
as his home was supposed to be finished
but as you know everybody that's gone
through construction knows
if they say it'll be done in may it'll
be done in september
so
he
his house is running late so we have our
plane tickets we're coming nick is
opening rock of ages and zach's like
we're all gonna live together for like
two weeks so it was me
nick ma elvis our two dogs zap and his
dog all living in the two-bedroom
two-bath guest cottage
then oh my god zach's groping florence
arrives and so then it's zach and
florence their dog
nick elvis and i and our two dogs all
living happily together i mean what the
f i mean uh who who went crazy first had
to be zach ironically no zack
loved it zach is used to living by
himself and so he all of a sudden had
this big family where every night we
were cooking dinner and eating together
drinking wine and having a bowl he was
like not even wanting to go
thank god for florence because florence
came in and was like we're moving into
your house these people need their space
we need our space we're doing this and
so um
she she was a saving grace i mean we all
actually did get along living together
so well and it was really really fun it
just was hard with the baby because nick
and i and elvis were all in
one room together i mean it was it was
tough and it was tough on me i went
through a little postpartum but we
actually all did i mean you know again
you look back retrospectively and you're
like oh my god like that time was so
magical that we were all living together
at zack's house i always look at those
times i had times where my friend tom
and deneen stayed with me up while i was
filming smallville and we lived in a
houseboat and they stayed with me for
months on end and those are the happiest
times of my life i feel like you know i
live alone you know i have a dog but i
do get lonely i'd like to entertain i
like to people to come over i like to
barbecue and hang out and movie nights
and you know my grandmother's always
like when are you going to get someone
when are you going to have a kid this is
the best thing in the world for you what
are you and i'm like i'm not doing this
just so i can so to make you happy
that's what i always think and then i
have the kid and then you end up dying
you know you're you're 93 years old i
don't want to
and we have these conversations probably
every week but there is there is a sense
of
i don't know what it is security some
comfort having people you love around
you and it just that warm feeling that
that it presents so um ironically we all
lived together very very well and really
never once had a weird spat i mean we
all really
respected each other's space and had a
really great time right that's very so
sorry to get a little a little dark but
like we know the inevitable but
you know
[Music]
when did this first start where nick
started to get sick and you i mean we
won't go through it entirely but like
we'll skip over some things but like you
know i'm sure
you're thinking this is not a big deal
in the beginning correct like this is a
young guy you never had you explained
yeah oh yeah i mean it was it was weird
nick i think was a bit of a
hypochondriac with sickness so
he was saying from day one i have used i
have this thing i have this thing is
what he kept saying and
because his only symptom was that he was
tired i was like no you don't and it all
started on my birthday night
and um and then you know for the next
two weeks he basically just slept all
day every day but
yeah i was not worried about it because
i was like this isn't a symptom of covet
so
you definitely don't have povet you can
smell you can taste you don't have a
fever you're not coughing you're just
tired i thought he was depressed which
nick could easily go into uh you know
because he's he's a performer he's a
musician
and everything in that world just got
you know and all of our world's gotten
cut
so um yeah i didn't think anything of it
and when did you realize this this is
something i didn't get extremely worried
until um like the night before we i took
him to the emergency room um that would
have been march 29th and um i got
worried because his breathing was really
bad for the first time i was like
you can't breathe like you're having a
hard time like walking from the kitchen
table to the sofa which is like
12 feet like
what's you know that's when i got scared
right and when even when i took him to
the emergency room i was like i'll pick
you up in two hours i was like i
literally was like i'll just not walk
around third street with elvis i'll pick
you up in a couple hours and so what do
they say they they
he's in the emergency rooms doctor calls
you or calls you in no no they call you
they call you you can't go anywhere so
they call you and what do they say nick
called me the doctor didn't even call me
nick called me and he said amanda they
want to keep me overnight they're gonna
they put me on some oxygen to help me
with my breathing they want to do some
further tests they're testing me for
covet and they're keeping me here
overnight just to make sure i'm okay and
i was like oh okay gosh all right well
i'll talk to you tomorrow again not
being like
i don't know and he had no real
pre-existing conditions nothing
i mean it's just he was never sick nick
never was sick he was like if he had a
cold it was like wow we have a cold i
mean he was like never sick so jump
ahead
when you realize this is this is really
serious and i can't believe i'm going
through this [ __ ]
i didn't think it was really serious
until the day um that they called and
told me that he died on the table for
two minutes
because and i'll say that because the
the 10 days leading up to that when he
was in the icu even though the icu was
scary
every day i was getting reports back
from nick's doctor that he's doing great
we're pro where progress and progress
every day
numbers are looking great we'll take him
off the ventilator on you know thursday
he'll be home by the next wednesday like
doing great amanda everything's great
and so i was like okay so i was you know
hanging out with elvis trying to like be
the best single parent i could be
and uh managing everything at home
trying to manage my fitness business
because that was the only thing that was
making money for us at the time
so i was just like you know great he'll
be home by wednesday and
boy this this has been crazy you know
but wow so they just keep throwing kind
of false hope at you kind of well or
maybe not even false hope they're
throwing things at you that this is
gonna be okay that was the truth he was
progressing everything was going great
he was gonna get off the ventilator
everything was literally like if it was
on the incline of like we're gonna he's
gonna be completely fine
and then they called the morning um uh
of april 10th and said you know
the exact opposite that overnight he
spiked a fever
his heart stopped
he went into septic shock and he's on an
hour like a minute to minute basis and
every hour counts
we'll let you know and i was like
that's when i was like what
you know i just got like chills like it
just
i'm shocked and i know the story i mean
i know what ends up happening
but it's it's absolutely got to be the
most shocking thing to ever hear when
you think okay
my husband's gonna be back and things
are getting better and then all of a
sudden hey this is this is life and this
is what just happened
yeah
yeah and how long after did it take
before uh
before he passed
well that was april 10th and then so
july 5th he passed so
yeah it was a good long um
i mean it was like around 95 days i mean
from when he
was in the icu on a ventilator to the
day he passed
and you documented a lot of this on
instagram yeah i did i started
documenting it um
when he
when he went into the icu is when i
started documenting it because
i was on i was online every day offering
free fitness classes and promoting my
fitness business
and it felt like i was leading a double
life to just be like on you know insta
lives every day being like okay guys
here we go 20 minute workout smiling and
happy and then
you know having my husband in the icu so
on top of of that also i was like
my husband's in the icu with apparently
covet and his only symptom was that he
was sleeping so i feel like other people
should know this in case you're at home
sleeping and you don't think you have
coped so it was you know something i
decided to go on and share because
i just was leading a double life and i
wanted people to know that you know what
was going on with nick
and i had already had like you know
what i thought was a lot of followers at
the time i still do like 50 000
followers and
and i am i was a very active person on
social media anyways a very honest like
what's going on in my day kind of person
on social media so
you know it was just like natural to get
on and say what was going on well i
think yeah
you know and then everything exploded
well i mean to say your
inspiration is just
you're on another level and i think
that's why people gravitate towards you
because you have so much positivity but
you also divulge the truth i mean you
really tell the truth and
i think you know that's why people like
you i think you're a great not only
super talented but like crazy likeable
and
that's that's cool i mean you know one
of the questions i thought i was like
you know what do you do to get through
the day and but i remember what you said
when you were going through a terrible
time
on broadway and then you put your makeup
on you put this and you
i mean i mean what do you do do you have
a routine that cause you know people all
across the world they we they suffer
they suffer loss every day and
but hearing you speak i mean maybe
they'll get something out of like what
is your sort of routine in the morning
or what you do to to maybe give you a
little bit of sunshine i mean i start
every day with a positive thought i put
it on my instagram i share it with
everybody it's something i've done now
for like five years i just the first
thing i put in my head um i i'm very i'm
a grateful person i every day i drive to
cbs i say a prayer and just like thank
god for everything that i have in my
life
even if all i can think about that day
is that it's sunny like it's a sunny day
um so i i try to find those like
beautiful things in the day i exercise a
lot because for me that's like my number
one mental health like stress an anxiety
reliever put on great music
get my jump rope or start dancing or
start doing anything go on a walk it
just clears my head and puts me in like
a different space
and um
yeah i don't know those that's kind of
like my my go-to's my three go-to's
because you you do get anxiety do you
have anxiety attacks do you and so so
for you uh working out is really what
helps you get that heart going get
things moving you have to do it if you
don't do that you're going to fall apart
yes
it's like it's uh to me it's the best
thing you can do for yourself you can
either sit there and ponder and let your
head go
or you can get up
put some music on so it distracts those
thoughts and just like focus on moving
your body and using it and breathing and
circulating your blood and just you know
doing things what do you do when you
start to go down a dark path when you
start to go oh my god why me why this
why this all those those feelings come
up and you just feel like it was
yesterday that happened probably you
feel like that every day but what how do
you stop that it depends sometimes i'll
be honest sometimes uh i just have to
let myself go down that dark path for a
smidge so
like the last time that happened was
nick's anniversary um this past you know
july 5th was a really hard day for me i
spent like the first probably four hours
in bed
um i just was like i was at the beach i
was in a beautiful resort at cabo i put
the black shades down and i just cried
and laid in bed and felt sorry for
myself then
i was like okay i can't do this all day
because when i'm i'm not serving nick's
memory by doing this i'm not making i'm
not being a good mom by doing this i'm
not even making myself feel good by
doing this so
i did a um i did a guided meditation
session with a girlfriend of mine which
really really helped kind of get me out
of my funk
and then i went out to the pool and
played with elvis which got my mind off
of things and then um i did some
self-care and i got a massage
and i just uh forced myself to to do
things to
do things that make me happy like when
nick passed it was my goal every day to
do one thing a day that made me happy
one
and that's all if one led to 10 that was
great but if one
and i was done and then i went back to
crying at least i did one thing that day
that made me happy and how often do you
hear from zach braff oh all the time
he's my neighbor and uh you know we're
all the he's one of my best friends in
the entire world we hang out and talk
all the time yeah he's a really good
soul yeah yes this has been really
amazing it's been you know
uplifting at times and then you know
it's obviously what it is i mean it's
it's it's a terrible thing that happened
and i just i just love what you're doing
um this is
i have a patreon account and so i have
these wonderful patrons that get to ask
questions it's called [ __ ] talking so
these are just rapid fire you could just
be quick if you can sophie m i see you
joined the talk do you have a dream
guest you'd like to interview oh um
michelle obama or julia roberts or
jennifer aniston jennifer aniston really
that's a big one you're a big fan of
hers oh i do i really like her cindy h
how have your family and friends rallied
for you any any special stories you're
comfortable sharing is there one story
in particular that you
that just you think of when you think of
your family or your friends yeah my
really good friends molly and trevor
tuttle and jono hart
from day one when nick got sick they
they knew how important music was to
lift your spirits and and they
all of a sudden would just show up at
like the most magical times you'll read
about it in the book
in trevor's truck covered in twinkle
lights and jono you know arranging
nick's song and just playing playing
songs for us and singing
nick's song and then singing outside our
door i mean it was like out of a movie
couldn't write it i love it um so the
book is live your life it's a memoir
it's new york times bestseller you guys
got to get this uh we only touched
didn't even scratch the surface of what
you know she talks about she's going to
talk about in this book or that she does
write about in this book um leanne p
says i think this sums it up you are a
kind and beautiful woman both inside out
you bring joy to so many and i just want
to say thank you for spending the time
with me i really i really appreciate it
i feel like i got to know you a little
bit so
thank you and and all my best to you and
elvis and the family and your friends
and your career i wish you the absolute
best so thank you thank you thanks so
much for having me today finally i got
you on here
thank you for listening i i hope you
enjoyed that interview amanda was
wonderful wasn't she very nice yeah
great story about the rockettes which
which i kept saying rock set
but uh you know what are you gonna do i
do that i tend to mix up words i think
we all do that every once in a while
don't we rock set rock set well roxette
was a band in the 80s which we uh which
we talked about but it wasn't she was in
the rock yet she did she's done so much
and she's so inspirational and her
instagrams are pretty uh
pretty wonderful she's she's great yeah
if my mom met her she'd say why don't
you marry her i'm like well i mean no i
don't my grandmother would say the thing
why are you single why are you 49
why why are you saying you're a great
guy michael they ask why are you 49 yeah
why are you 49 why like i have a choice
thank you again for uh listening to the
podcast again if you want to follow us
on the instagram twitter and all that
stuff it's at inside you podcast on
instagram and facebook and inside of you
pod on the twitter uh you can watch the
show on youtube i appreciate you guys
writing a review watching listening all
that stuff um
and also if you wanna go to the online
store it's the inside of you online
store you can get tons of merch funko
pop lex luthor things there's just so
much you could get on there just take a
look it's a lot of fun and also my band
sunspin.com you could book a zoom with
me for god's sakes and uh
you could uh book the band and get cool
merch there and lastly but not leastly
is the the patreon um just go to
patreon.com inside if you want to join
help the podcast out a little more it
really helps if you're enjoying this and
you want to help a little more uh
there's nothing like it uh patreon.com
inside of you uh also i should mention
i'm going to be at dragoncon in atlanta
september 4th that weekend the saturday
and sunday and then um september 11th
weekend i will be in lexington kentucky
and september
i believe 24th let me check me on that
but i'll be at the mountaineer con in
west virginia so three cons coming up in
september just me check my twitter at
inside at my the at michael rosenbaum
because they couldn't i didn't have
enough for the letters baum so i had to
put and bum
what the hell is that about let's get
into it let's uh read the top patreons
these are people who give a little bit
more and substantially help the podcast
nancy d leah s trisha f sarah v little
lisa yukiko jill e bryan h mama g nico p
jerry w
robert b jason w poffy and kristen okay
gosh yeah i could just throw that at him
he just nails it emilia oh allison el
raj see joshua d emily s cjp samantha m
jennifer and stacy l jenness jamal f
janelle
b
kimberly e mike e el don
99 more ramirez santiago m sarah f chad
w liam p jeanine r ray a maya p maddie s
shannon d matt w blind and james james r
chris h dave h spider-man chase sheila g
brad d ray h tabitha t tom n liliana a
uh michelle k hi
michael s talia m betsy d
claire m laura l chad l rochelle nathan
e marion e meg k janelle p travel dan n
o ajetta uh jetta jetta lorraine g
veronica k big stevie w kendall t carol
d angel m rhiannon c cory k super sam
emily c coleman g
dev nixon michelle a liz l jeremy c andy
t few more left here the top tier
patrons that get their name read off at
the end of every episode and they're
wonderful and they really help the
podcast uh cody r sebastian k gavinator
and h david c elliott m john b
brandy d yvore camille s bono or bano hi
bano i messed it up didn't i v c the c
huh joey m and p.t scarborough
those are the top tier patrons folks and
uh i'm sorry i didn't know we had an oil
baron yeah is that what it was yeah the
pt scarborough that's what a name that
is you're gonna be you've got to be
really rich to have that name i think
uh i love doing this i love you guys
listening i've been doing it for a while
now i love all the support i love all
the messages
i may not get back to all your messages
right away it takes me some time um i'm
busy as i know you are but i certainly
appreciate the support and are aware of
all of you listening and watching and
all that so um keep listening tell your
friends email them text them make sure
they listen and watch the show uh from
the hollywood hills in in the los
angeles california uh i'm michael
rosenbaum i'm waving to that camera up
there hi i'm ryan
i'm waving at the camera i'm waving over
the camera you guys are great thank you
for allowing to be inside of each and
every one of you i hope you have a
glorious week
and uh much love to you all right
[Music]